West Virginia public schoolteachers will
return to work tomorrow after their
statewide walkout their five percent
raise ends afford a strike over low pay
and rising insurance costs they're not
alone in their fight for higher salaries
in Arizona earnings of elementary school
teachers are nearly the country's lowest
when adjusted for the cost of living
averaging around $42,000 that's about
$13,000 less than the national average
Jamie yuccas met kindergarten teachers
in Phoenix who were making sacrifices
outside the classroom and I would eat
them in a boat and I would eat them with
a the thrill of seeing a child learn has
kept Laura Mayer and Raquel munos in the
classroom for more than a decade Ok Go
Ahead glue on artists will get that both
women say they were drawn to the
creativity of the job it's nice to be
around all that energy I'm excited about
learning and I think when kids are
excited about learning they do better
but both have found the profession
challenging financially as have other
teachers nationwide across the country
inflation-adjusted teacher pay is
declining down more than 15-hundred
dollars between 1996 and 2015 during
that same period incomes for all other
college graduates rose by almost $6,500
munos is a single mother of two who
recently chose to move back in with her
parents I wanted my children to have a
home and it really I didn't see it
happening anytime soon so I moved back
with family saving up and once I can get
my home that's my plan the single place
setting mayor took a second job at
cratenbarrel to supplement her income
things would be really tight if I were
just living on my salary do you ever
think about leaving and doing something
else I think about it all the time she's
not alone in Arizona 42% of teachers
left the profession within a recent
three-year period experts say it's a
nationwide problem the most recent data
and the national levels show that about
8% of teachers are leaving each year
losing so many teachers is also costing
taxpayers recruitment rehiring and
training reportedly add up to about
two billion dollars each year high
turnover can also have a big impact on
kids high turnover rates actually
reduced student achievement for all the
kids in the school not just the ones
whose teachers have been replaced in
West Virginia it took a promise raised
from the governor to end the four-day
strike
but in Arizona the State Superintendent
is hoping to increase the sales tax to
give teachers there a raise we have to
make sure that they're paid in
accordance with how important their job
is do you feel valued mmm
do I feel valued
I feel valued by parents
I feel valued by people that I work with
and they truly value the work they do
and what nothing more than to keep doing
it for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Phoenix you just want to
they are valued they are valued but it's
interesting Alex she had to hesitate
before she answered it it's one of those
stories that you go it just doesn't make
any sense that they don't get the pay
they deserve for the difference that
they make you know country enthusiasm is
infectious and how can you pass that on
to kids if you're not enthusiastic
because you're just barely trying to
keep up with your bills and all the
studies will show you early childhood
education is critical to success later
on in life we value you teachers now
there everybody can name a teacher that
changed their law absolutely everybody
can